hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
einem kanal in diesem video zeige ich
dir sechs methoden mit denen du deine
ernte überschüsse im sommer halver
machen kannst wir versuchen ja als
familie das ganze jahr über aus unserem
eigenen garten zu essen und da ist das
haltbarmachen natürlich super wichtig
bei uns läuft der einkauf tätig war hat
sie den ganzen sommer über weil wir eben
die ernte überschüsse die wir im sommer
haben haltbar machen damit wir im winter
immer noch tomaten zucchini auberginen
und obst obst ist auch etwas was einem
im winter supermarkt wenn man das nicht
im laden kauft damit wir das eben aus
unserer vorratskammer essen können und
in diesem video zeige ich dir sechs
techniken mit denen du deine ernte
haltbar machen kannst wir verwenden
persönlich drei von diesen techniken um
quasi den gesamten winter vor ort für
unsere familie anzulegen
eine der sechs techniken finde ich
überhaupt nicht so empfehlenswert
darüber werde ich auf sprechen aber ich
möchte dir einfach einen überblick geben
sodass du sagen kannst okay ich hab
jetzt super viele zucchini was mache ich
mit denen ich könnte die so reife machen
so oder ich könnte auch das mit ihnen
machen und deswegen gebe ich dir einen
überblick über diese sechs helfer
machten techniken für deine ernte viel
spaß
[Musik]
technik nummer eins ist das fermentieren
das ist meiner meinung nach eine der
besten wenn ich die beste technik um
gemüse haltbar zu machen mit obst machen
wir das nicht aber mit gemüse denn das
hat so so so unglaublich viele vorteile
wenn du gemüse fermentiert hält zum
beispiel die vitamine und spurenelemente
die vermehren sich sogar in den
fermentern noch weil die
milchsäurebakterien kommunizieren
miteinander und dabei noch mehr vitamine
herstellen das ist total abgefahren das
tolle daran ist dass du so gut wie jedes
gemüse durch fermentation halter machen
kannst kommentieren ist ja in den
letzten jahren wieder so ein bisschen
zum trend geworden da muss man aber
aufpassen denn viele der rezepte die man
im internet findet sind nicht darauf
ausgelegt dass das gemüse möglichst
lange haltbar ist wir sind vor allem
darauf ausgelegt dass man eben was
fermentiert das kann man möglichst
schnell essen und dann hat man eben
diese gesundheitlichen vorteile weil da
super viele darmbakterien drin sind also
bakterien die unsere darmflora aufbauen
weil das über viele vitamine enthält
spurenelemente wie schon gesagt es ist
super gesund fermentiert das gemüse zu
essen
die meisten kennen das ja vor allem von
sauerkraut also sauerkraut ist
kommentiert aber wenn man sauerkraut im
laden kauft dann ist das wieder gekocht
also das ist sozusagen kommentiert aber
danach noch mal eingekocht damit es
gleich bleibend sauber ist und ja nicht
irgendwie über brodelt weil wir dann
merkt man dass das schon ein lebendiger
prozess ist und dann ja kann man das
eben nicht so homogen verkaufen wenn man
das als lebendiges sauerkraut verkauft
das heißt das sauerkraut dass man im
laden bekommt ist leider schon wieder
toth gekocht also diese ganzen bakterien
sind da einfach schon wieder abgekocht
so dass eben auch wenn das gemüse weiter
umzusetzen also ein super grund mal
sauerkraut zu herzustellen aber das kann
man eben wie gesagt mit allen möglichen
gemüsen machen das einzige gemüse mit
dem ich das nicht machen würde wären ja
so blattsalate die werden sehr schnell
matschig oder zucchini die kann man
vielleicht nach ein zwei wochen noch
essen aber die sind einfach nicht
lagerfähig wenn man die fermentiert aber
sonst hat man eine riesengroße vielfalt
von gemüsen die man fermentieren kann
das würde ich also jedem ans herz legen
das mal auszuprobieren das war ja auch
früher für die seefahrer zum beispiel
total wichtig weil das so ihr vitamin
vorrat absehbar also dass sie dann auf
ihrer langen reise immer noch genügend
vitamine zur verfügung hatten was ab
ziemlich toll es ist das fermentierte
gemüse sich ohne kühlung sehr lange
lagert wir haben das einfach in einem
ungeheizten treppenhaus da lagen werden
wir unsere vermengte wir haben auch
keinen kühlen keller
das fragen auch über alle wie könnte ich
mich denn irgendwie den winter über
selbst versorgen wenn ich gar keinen
keller ab indem ich sachen einlagern
kann das haben wir auch nicht
also wir machen das alles einfach in den
ungeheizten raum und das funktioniert
mit verbänden super gut man hat keinen
input von strom oder sonst irgendwas man
kann es super einfach lagern wenn man
ein paar sachen beachtet und das ist
eine ganz tolle sache um den ganzen
winter über super abwechslungsreich aus
dem eigenen garten zu essen wenn ihr
wollt dass ich mal eine anleitung zum
fermentieren filme oder vielleicht ein
rezept filme dann schreibt mir das gern
mal unten in die kommentare da hätte ich
richtig lust drauf ansonsten könnt ihr
euch gerne meine texte runterladen habe
ich alle schritte aufgeführt wie man
beim fermentieren beachten sollte
das ist die checkliste wintervorrat da
stehen auch ganz viele andere schlaue
sachen drin
die einem weiterhelfen ein
selbstversorger winter vorrat anzulegen
die checkliste verlege ich euch einfach
mal hier unter dem video in der video
beschreibung die zweite technik ist das
einkochen alle die
meine vorrats grammatur gesehen haben
werden wahrscheinlich wissen dass ich
süchtig danach bin einzukochen ich finde
das ist so eine tolle methode wenn man
die sachen so einfach verwenden kann
dann gerade wenn man mal einem
stressigen tag hat hat man sein
selbstgemachtes fast wo da kann man
einfach ein glas tomatensoße aus dem
schrank holen kann in windeseile eine
lasagne zusammen basteln und hat ein
supertolles denn aus dem eigenen garten
ohne dass man dann noch viel aufwand
damit betreiben muss es ist so eine
tolle methode also ja ich bin auch immer
ganz stolz auf mein eindruck regal
ich freue mich da immer schon diebisch
drauf wenn das im herbst dann richtig
falls und die alle gläser zu sortieren
kann wie in unserem kleinen eigenen
supermarkt so dass wir dann immer
einfach nur ins regal gehen müssen und
dann können wir uns da unsere zehn
glauben holen und ja was ihr wenn ihr
die tour gesehen habt dann wisst ihr
dass wir alle möglichen sachen haltbar
machen wir haben da ja schon so unsere
familienrezepte wenn ihr in meinem
probst und gemüse haltbar machen kurs
mit dabei seid dann habt ihr die ja auch
alle und es freut mich auch immer so arg
zu sehen wie es dann bei euch aussieht
wenn ihr eure ganzen schätze haltbar
gemacht habt das macht einfach
wahnsinnig stolz oder jeder der das
schon mal gemacht hat der kann es glaube
ich irgendwie nachempfinden einkaufen
das auch super universell ich lernte
hier nochmal die gemüse das obst einen
dem man durch einkochen haltbar machen
kann das ist also eine technik mit der
man super viel unterschiedliche sachen
machen kann
es ist noch ganz ganz wichtig dass man
beim einfachen beachtet das gemüse das
ohne essig eingekocht wird also so
ziemlich alle gemüse die man ein kochen
will und fleisch mit einem druck ein
kochkessel haltbar gemacht werden müssen
weil sonst botulismus bakterien im glas
entstehen könnten die sind potenziell
tödlich also das ist eine sache da
sollte man sich mit auskennen wenn man
ein kocht ich mach da demnächst auch
noch mal ein video drüber weil ich das
super super wichtig finde und weil das
in deutschland irgendwie noch gar nicht
so richtig angekommen ist in vielen
anderen
dann ist es total normal dass man das
anständig haltbar macht also dass man
gemüse und fleisch immer einem
druckkessel einkocht in deutschland ist
es irgendwie ja noch so ein bisschen
klingt also ein bisschen hinterher der
sich demnächst mal ein video wo ich euch
zeige wie man eben botulismus sicher ein
kocht und mal über das thema sprechen
weil das ist was aus mir super am herzen
liegt aber das soll jetzt niemanden
abschrecken also ihr könnt superviel
einfach nur das ist auch sicher solange
man sich eben an die richtigen techniken
hält einige gemüse wie zum beispiel
kürbis trocken erbsen trockenboden
knoblauch zwiebeln lauch nüsse muss man
überhaupt nicht verarbeiten um sie
haltbar zu machen die muss man nur
trocken lagern knoblauch muss man zum
beispiel erstmal aufhängen luftig nach
der ernte so dass er gut abtrocknen kann
übrigens wenn ihr euren knoblauch noch
nicht geerntet habe dann das ist jetzt
echt höchste zeit den aus der erde zu
holen dann einfach zu bündeln bündeln
und aufhängen ich mache das immer im
gewächshaus da trocknen die dann richtig
durch und wenn sie richtig
durchgetrocknet sind dann kann man sie
eben trocken lagern wir machen das auch
einfach in einem ungeheizten raum hier
im treppenhaus das ist gar kein problem
und so halten die sich ewig langer so
wir haben jetzt noch knoblauch vom
letzten jahr der fängt jetzt gerade an
so kleine grüne spitzen zu bilden aber
ja meine güte ist weg trotzdem noch und
die nächste ernte steht ja schon wieder
vor der tür wir haben auch immer noch
kürbis vom letzten jahr hier stehen
der fängt jetzt auch langsam an zu
schwächeln aber viele leute glauben
immer gar nicht dass man die so lange
aufbewahren kann ohne kühlen keller ohne
irgendwelche abgefahrenen sagen wir mal
co2 kann man oder sonst irgendwas man
kann wenn man die sachen richtig erntet
und nach der ernte richtig aufbewahrt
dann kann man die super gut auch einfach
trocken naturbelassen
das machen wir auch super super gerne
stellt euch mal die gemüse ein
oder die pflanzen allen die man trocken
einfach im haus lagern kann und dann
sprechen wir noch mal über das einmieten
das gehört für mich so ein bisschen dazu
also das naturbelassene lagern von zb
wurzelgemüse funktioniert indem man die
in sand einschlägt da haben wir einfach
draußen im garten eine
waschmaschinentrommel die wir in den
boden eingegraben haben da kann man auch
ganz viele waschmaschinentrommel einen
graben oder irgendwie eine andere art
miete bauen so dass man mehr platz hat
und da lagern sie dann einfach möhren
rote beete und so weiter
die kann man natürlich auch im beet
stehen lassen da gibt es
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten die man
da hat und da sind wir immer ganz froh
dass wir eben auch die möglichkeit haben
das einfach einzumieten da kann man auch
kohl einmieten wohl kann man übrigens
auch einfach mit wurzel ausreißen und
wenn man den kühlen keller hat einfach
umgedreht aufhängen und solange der sich
auch ganz gut aber wir packen den
einfach in die elite unterhält er sich
auch wunderbar die meisten kohle sind ja
aber auch relativ winterhart so dass man
sich da gar nicht so viele sorgen machen
muss wenn man die gut schützt vor dem
kalten winterwetter technik nummer vier
ist das einfrieren das machen wir nur in
sehr kleinem umfang wir fielen vor allem
unser fleisch eines verarbeiten wir
entweder zu wurst kochen es ein oder wir
frieren es ein dafür ist die
gefriertruhe also super ab und zu führen
wir auch obst oder gemüse allen aber
eher in ganz kleinem stil also das feld
bei uns eigentlich gar nicht ins gewicht
weil wir damit echt nicht so gute
erfahrungen gemacht haben wir schlachten
ja unsere eigenen tiere und wenn man ein
tier das man auf gezogen hat und dass
man das einem so ans herz gewachsen ist
dass einem so viel bedeutet wenn man
sich dann dazu entscheidet okay wir
werden dieses tier jetzt essen dann muss
man dem finde ich absolut gerecht werden
und man muss jeden fetzen von dem tier
verarbeiten man muss möglichst leckere
sachen daraus kochen um das irgendwie
anständig zu handhaben
wären das dann überhaupt an stände geht
weil im prinzip man tötet ein tier also
es ist eine harte angelegenheit wenn man
seine eigenen tiere ist und deswegen
finde ich es immer super wichtig dass
ich sichere methoden verwendet um das
fleisch haltbar zu machen und auch meine
ernten hier liegt mir natürlich auch am
herzen aber natürlich nicht so wie
werden wir jetzt eine ziege geschlachtet
haben und die in unserem tiefkühler
liegt und dann der strom ausfällt und
wir bauen müssen ob das fleisch
vielleicht vergammelt weil das ist uns
letztes jahr passiert das war so
nervenaufreibend und zum glück ist der
strom nach 24 stunden wieder angegangen
und unsere tiefkühltruhe kann solange
die temperatur aufrechterhalten auch
ohne strom
aber das hatten wir noch mal vor augen
geführt dass ich kein als großer freund
vom einfrieren bin ich kann euch mal
zeigen was wir zurzeit noch drin haben
aber wie gesagt ich versuche vor allem
die anderen techniken zu verwenden um
unsere ernte und auch unser fleisch
haltbar zu machen
technik nummer fünf ist das deren oder
trocken in deiner ernte das ist
natürlich auch eine tolle möglichkeit
ich mache das vor allem gerne wenn ich
die energie der sonne nutzen kann
aber das mache ich wirklich nur mit sehr
wenigen pflanzen zum beispiel mit
kräutern die hänge ich sehr gerne
einfach hier oben luft dick in unserer
kirche auf an den kronleuchter oder
irgendwo an einem regal
das sieht auch immer ziemlich hübsch aus
finde ich wenn man über eine kleine
kräuter sträußchen hängen hat ich
trockne auch gerne frühlingszwiebeln
wenn wir welche übrig haben einfach in
der sonne auf einem tuch an einem heißen
tag oder 1 23 heißen tagen immer mal
wieder
das ganze so dass die von allen seiten
stellen trocken werden und dann kann man
die im winter mit heißem wasser
aufgießen
dann hat man wieder sozusagen so instant
frühlingszwiebeln das mache ich ganz
gerne aber ich bin kein großer freund
von der automaten wenn man dann zum
beispiel tomaten dirt oder rote beete
dort dann haben wir auf die erfahrung
gemacht dass die sachen ziemlich schnell
schimmeln
vielleicht haben wir es einfach nicht so
gut gelagert aber ich fand es einfach
generell nicht so anfänger freundlich
und es kann mehr schief gehen als bei
den anderen techniken und deswegen
dürfen wir nur sehr sehr eingeschränkt
also bzw
wir trocknen eher als dass wir dürfen
wenn ihr gute erfahrungen gemacht hat
mit dem dürren und vielleicht noch tipps
habe wie man das ganze so gestalten kann
das ist dann eben nicht schimmelt dann
freue ich mich auf jeden fall
und ich denke viele andere auch wenn ihr
unten in kommentar da last aber wie
gesagt wir sind nicht so große freunde
vom dürren und verlassen uns eher auf
die anderen halber machen techniken die
sechste technik ist das einlegen in
alkohol salz öl oder essig das machen
wir auch nicht so gerne mit essig ja da
finde ich es immer schwierig weil mir
das einfach nicht schmeckt und ich weiß
dass es sehr fehlen da draußen auch so
wird weil ich kriege immer nachrichten
und ich hasse haltbar machen weil das
schmeckte mal so eklig nach essig kann
doch mal von meiner oma habe ich
überhaupt keine lust drauf
also ich glaube viele leute da draußen
mögen das einfach nicht ich auch nicht
in alkohol einlegen auch nicht ich
trinke auch fast kein alkohol also das
ist auch nicht so wirklich mein
geschmack wenn es dir schmeckt und du
das ganz toll finde es macht das
natürlich aber beim einlegen in öl muss
sich als echte mal noch ein wörtchen
sagen weil einlegen und in öl
funktioniert dadurch luftabschluss also
da werden die bakterien den wert wird
einfach die lebensgrundlage durch
luftabschluss entzogen allerdings können
die botulismus bakterien über die wir
schon gesprochen haben die auch beim
einkochen gefährlich sind in öl unter
luftabschluss eben weiter arbeiten sich
weiter vermehren
sie können ihre toxine produzieren
sodass du auch beim einlegen in öl
probleme mit botulismus bekommen kannst
das ist natürlich selten dass das
passiert aber wenn es passiert dann
reichen oft schon kleine mengen aus um
botulismus zu bekommen das ist eine
krankheit oder eine
lebensmittelvergiftung die sehr schnell
tödlich enden kann und deswegen würde
ich da wirklich von absehen lebensmittel
und öl zu lagern in essig alkohol und
salz ist das kein problem
wie gesagt ich bin es einfach nicht
lecker aber lässt er die finger von dem
einlegen in öl denn das wilde ich
ehrlich gesagt wirklich nicht riskieren
an eurer stelle wenn wir euch jetzt auch
gerade die große ernte schwämme vor der
tür steht und ihr lust habt mehr für den
winter haltbar zu machen euch eine
kleine winter vorratskammer anzulegen
dann ladet euch wie gesagt gerne meine
checkliste herunter da habe ich ganz
viel für euch aufgeführt zum beispiel
welche gemüse kann ich mit welchen
techniken haltbar machen
wie funktioniert das mit dem einkaufen
wie kann ich fermentieren sodass es
nicht schimmelt könnt ihr euch gerne
einfach die liste kostenlos in der video
beschreibung herunterladen ich habe
diesen sommer noch ganz viele andere
videos zum haltbarmachen geplant und
möchte auch gerne rezepte mit euch
teilen und euch mehr über die
unterschiedlichen techniken erzählen
also lasst gerne ein abo da und drückt
auch die glocke damit ihr informiert
werdet wenn die nächsten videos
erscheinen ansonsten freue ich mich auch
immer über einen daumen nach oben das
hilft wirklich ungemein
auf youtube also wenn ihr meinen kanal
unterstützen wollt dann ist das immer
gerne gesehen ansonsten findet ihr da
drüben meine vorratskammer tour wenn ihr
mal sehen wollt wie unsere
selbstversorger vorratskammer denn
aussieht und vielleicht auch planen
wollt wie ihren den jahresbedarf für
eure familie halber macht schaut man da
drüben bei da unten ist auch noch ein
spannendes video ansonsten sehen wir ins
nächsten samstag wieder bis dahin